so jetzt schauen wir noch mal auf einen
anderen spd mann der sich heute geäußert
hat unser business gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach und es gibt endlich gute
nachrichten die inzidenz fallen die
sogenannte sommer welle bei der korona
inzidenz ist überstanden aber vor dem
nach dem sommer maniche kommt eben noch
der herbst sich ja genau der herbst der
steht das sei noch bevor und vor dem
warnt gesundheitsminister lauterbach
unermüdlich er selbst er hat ja gerade
seine corona infektion überstanden muss
er jetzt wieder vor die presse am
vormittag in berlin schauen wir es hätte
also gesagt hat zu den krone regeln dann
ab herbst kommen nicht für jeden
nachvollziehbar
würde dann länder seit ich die
möglichkeit bestehen ab dem ersten
zehnten und zwar incidents unabhängig
dass die länder für den innenraum einer
massen pflicht einführen also nur dass
es jeder versteht es ist eine
möglichkeit die ab dem ersten zehnten
besteht spielt die inzidenz eine rolle
spielt keine rolle die länder können das
machen ganz unabhängig von der inzidenz
müssen sie es dann machen sie müssen es
nicht machen wenn sie es aber machen
dann müssen sie eine ausnahme vorsehen
für die innenräume wo das masken tragen
ersetzt werden kann durch entweder da
einen impfausweis
genießen aus was welche testo
dann kann die masten sich aufgehoben
werden
muss man tatsächlich sich das ganze noch
mal genauer zu gemüte führen aber auch
beim thema impfungen ähnliche
verwirrungen so wirklich leicht
nachvollziehbar sind lauterbachs pläne
auch in diesem fall nicht
das erste argument ist dass das bedeutet
doch man muss sich dann drei alle drei
monate impfen lassen heißt natürlich
nicht so für die drei monate gehen wir
davon aus dass dann der schutz vor
infektionen gilt aber die impfungen
wirken natürlich viel länger und die
impf wirkung und auch die samba der mvhs
war es selbst von den drei monaten ja
gar nicht berührt somit wäre es nicht so
dass dann alle drei monate geben würde
das wird jetzt wollen wahrscheinlich
auch kein arzt tun sei nicht vorgesehen
sondern das ist die dauer wir glauben
dass die neuen impfungen auch vor
ansteckung schützen
also nicht nur verschwörung verlauf
sondern auch veranstaltung ich studiere
jetzt so entwickeln dass das länger das
sagen die neuen impfungen länger als
drei monate vor ansteckung schützen dann
würden wir diesen zeitraum drei monate
verlängert dann wurde das beispielsweise
4 motor fünf monate die das kann dann
verlängert werden was steht im gesetz
auch dämm normentwurf somit die drei
monate sind erst mal unsere schätzung
auf der grundlage der daten die wir
haben was man für drei monate auch bei
eine stärkung geschützt ist vor schweren
verlaufs man viel länger geschützt aber
dass man vor der für drei monate hat
dann quasi im ersatz einer maske weil
man wahrscheinlich vor ansteckung
geschützt ist die maske nicht tragen
muss das ist die logik dieses also
dieser vorgehensweise also da müssen wir
ein bisschen leichtigkeit aufklärungen
und deutlichkeit reinbringen das heißt
weiterhin verwirrung der
gesundheitsminister hat er gesagt er
hält an den regeln fest so richtig
verstanden hat die regeln ehrlich gesagt
noch niemand und viele befürchten muss
ich mich jetzt etwa alle drei monate
impfen lassen und mit was überhaupt wer
uns hilfe geholt und zwar ist unsere
bild chefreporterin erinnert ja es war
und sie kann gut was für einen herbst
wieder steuern und was genau die pläne
des gesundheitsministers vor sich her
gesehen er musste da selber teilweise
doch mal auf dem zettel schon wie jetzt
genau die regeln lauten man sollte
denken ein bisschen übungen in sachen
bruder aber es scheint es beginnt ein
jeden herbst aufs neue genau das sehe
ich ganz genauso wie ich habe das auch
mit viel verwunderung verfolgt gerade
und ich glaube was wir bräuchten wäre so
ein lexikon deutsch lauterbach
lauterbach deutsch weil es geht einfach
es geht drunter und drüber und man merkt
ja auch er gibt sich große mühe das zu
erklären er arbeitet viel mit
wahrscheinlich wohl vielleicht eventuell
aber so richtig klar dass da nicht ja
und das einzige was man dann wirklich
versteht und gehört hat ist kein grund
zur entwarnung wie sinnvoll ist es denn
jetzt im sommer wo wir jetzt in die
instanzen sinken die welle ist
eigentlich überstanden schon wieder den
corona herbst alarm auszurufen überhaupt
nicht das war ja auch thema in der
pressekonferenz dass man jetzt gerade an
ganz andere sachen denke dass viele
menschen auch müde geworden sind dass
krone natürlich permanent thema war weil
die ansteckungen hoch waren dass sie
aber jetzt gerade abflachen das ist ja
schon mal gut das hat man ja auch
festgestellter der pressekonferenz gut
dass sich die lage jetzt entspannt und
tatsächlich da wäre ich beim
bundeskanzler war es ab erstens hinten
ist das sehen wir dann schon allerdings
heißt es ja dann auch immer wieder
schnell man hätte sich vorher
vorbereiten müssen jetzt kommt die
politik immer wieder kurz vor knapp mit
irgendwelchen neuen regeln da hatten sie
auch das ganze jahr zeit wenn man es aus
der warte sieht muss man natürlich sagen
gut und gesundheitsminister der müsste
sich schon ein bisserl vorbereiten aber
das klingt jetzt nicht so richtig nach
vorbereitung das klingt ja nur nach
irgendwie machen was so wie wir es
vorher auch gemacht haben in der tat war
es ja vor allen dingen noch als ganz
große offene baustelle hat es einfach
die kommunikation mit den ländern weil
was er ja mehrfach angesprochen hat
nichts in stein gegossen noch ist nicht
geklärt nächste woche steht die nächste
schalter an mit den chefs der senats-
und staatskanzleien das würde ich einmal
ganz gepflegt abwarten weil das was wir
jetzt erlebt haben war ja sehr viel
widerspruch aus den ländern zu den
einzelnen punkten des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ich würde gerne
die nächste woche noch mal abwarten um
zu gucken was aus den ländern kommt also
da kann sich schon noch mal ein bisschen
was tun in der große knackpunkt ist ja
immerhin der zusammenhang mit dem test
mit den masken und mit der impfungen bei
vielen blieb einfach nur hängen moment
mal ich muss mich jetzt alle drei monate
impfen lassen damit ich ohne irgendeinen
extra also sprich ein test oder
irgendwas ins restaurant mal darf ohne
maske und das bleibt der lenker der
knackpunkt auch heute hat er da haben
wir festgehalten genauso und er selbst
verweist darauf dass da gar keine
verwirrung sei und versucht es zu
entkräften und sagt na ja er hätte ja
darauf hingewiesen dass man das in
absprache mit dem hausarzt machen soll
nur anfangs hat er gesagt es wäre gut
und mein um gut durch den sommer zu
kommen wäre das gut wenn auch jüngere
das beherzigen wurden nach rücksprache
mit dem hausarzt jetzt fängt er
plötzlich mit dem berghain barkeeper an
also was am ende da passiert man weiß es
einfach anfangen in
bergheim antworten oder der andere ist
wirklich sehr ganze vorstellung und
tatsächlicher ort sich mit allen
möglichen sachen anzustecken
[Musik]